visitors to Berkeley their more recent
innovation has been to run things
through the summer we currently have a
our first summer program running on
foundations of deep learning and the
other thing we've been doing is run
these summer clusters and smaller
activities that we can organize on a
shorter time scale for things that are
fast-moving and speculative and they're
just better suited to run something
perhaps more narrowly focused little
program and we've only run a few of
these but so far they seem to be really
really successful and the boot camp
today is part of the summer cluster on
they are correcting codes and high
dimensional expansion which starts today
so welcome welcome to that the goals of
the boot camp boot cats are intended to
be a kind of scientific and social
icebreaker put their cluster getting
everyone on the same page technically
but also they have a archival
educational purpose sort of recording a
state of the owner that particular field
is the videos of the talks I'm sure
you've all seen our website amazingly
popular further but the kind of
technical levels of the content I think
we passed two million views this
impressive so this cluster is supported
by the Patrick J McGovern Foundation so
thanks to them for that but big thank
you to the organizers of the boot camp
arete and I like that they're also the
organizers of the cost per se so thanks
to them for
as you can see although be good today
it's filled up with these issues
unfortunately we're hoping they'll get
resolved during this thing and I'll hand
over to to reap in just just one moment
I want to say a few words about
logistics we try to keep the Institute
and in particular these meeting rooms in
in good shape so we ask that you don't
bring tea and coffee and food in here
you know water is fine but there's other
things outside for the morning and
afternoon race we've got tea coffee and
snacks out here for lunches you're on
your own and today there's to do a long
and hopefully very social lunch break I
guess every going to say a little more
about their schedule if you want to keep
things in lockers in the hallway on the
far side of the ground wall here you'll
find lockers that you can use with a
thin coat for wireless access you've
probably already discovered how the
visitor works for everybody
and you indicate using Ed your own home
institution that too as I say I talked
to the livestream archive YouTube
channel and our website and Darren the
videographer here is going to be helping
the speakers connect up talk to him
about that and also a big THANK YOU to
the events coordinator Tom Thompson is
over here but also color well she and
Kevin hung put a lot of effort into the
local organization be thanks to me
we'll just take sorts of questions all
right
great to see you and we're going to
start the boot camp now as you see
unfortunately is not a wasn't able to
get the visa and so this is gonna cause
a bit of a schedule change because we
you know because of the time difference
having him talk later in the day is
going to be really late at night for him
so tomorrow the other talk II was gonna
give today will be spun til tomorrow
tomorrow we will give two hours in the
morning and you can look online for the
remaining schedule change tomorrow's
gonna be a slightly longer day today we
will instead of his tablet will shoot
things up and your town will top three
to four and then the reception will be
at four so forward again I just want to
thank Peter and the Simon things you did
for hosting us it's such a beautiful
place I'm so happy to be here and also
thanks for all the last minute they have
changes it was not so tribute to its
arranged so thanks
[Applause]
hi everybody can you hear me the basic
away from you all over there - I don't
know the left two people to the left
yeah okay very good morning to all of
you this is not that good morning for me
it's about 10 p.m. here in Bombay being
battered by the Indian monsoon outside I
was hoping to be there with the US team
but we decided otherwise and this has
been held for some administrative
processing and hopefully I should get it
in a couple of days and I'll join you
guys next week if everything works out
well yeah and in other so as I eat
mentioned because there's a slight
change thanks to assignments for
accommodating this last minute I will be
doing giving my talks all my talks
remotely and you don't want to be seen
with the top at 4 a.m. in the morning
you and me so all my my afternoon talks
are being moved to tomorrow and there's
going to be a schedule change in
announced anyway so much for that let's
get started let's go to the main topic
of the day that I plan to do so they
feel free to this is going to be
introductory talk so I don't have to
cover all the material that I plan to do
so feel free to interrupt me with
questions and this one I can I think I
can I do the test
I could hear people from all around the
window I can't see everybody feel free
to stop me as and when it's one I have a
sort of a white here too in which I can
write and answer questions as we keep
going along okay so what I plan to do in
this introductory talk this sort of gear
my motivations are sort of why move
towards working in this area Ida must
expand his philosophies I've been
working in this area for the last this
is three to four years and I would like
to give what's the motivation behind it
so the math community and the Combinator
X community have been working on it for
much much longer the TCS community has
got interested the last four five years
and write the high dimensions founders
just like the word expanders does not
refer to a single object it refers to
classes similar objects and what we will
see over the course of the boot camp is
very various objects of this flavor I'll
be talking about a particular type of
high dimension expanders are introduced
that during my talk your thumb and elite
will do us another but equivalent one in
their talks and you Lee will be giving
some no other notions of vitamin C
expanders in this dot the model so in
fact the main one is the bill my talk is
going to be structure this but the most
part of the talking about it off put
motivations and applications and I
actually come to the main what the high
damage to expanders are the very end of
the talk I'll introduce it I sort of
motivate why we care about such an
object even without defining this object
and you come to the actual definition
possibly at the very end of the in some
sense you'll be hearing the story from
me in which I will be delaying the
character of the main character of the
coterminous to the very end of the as I
had mentioned am abstract sort of three
things which I would like to sort of
concentrate in this talk is trying to
ask what are these objects which are
confidential expanders are these past
versions of these objects and why and
are these objects interesting and use in
fact I'll try to answer these three
questions in the reverse
so he saw us after having set the stage
and notation enough notation we'll start
off with an application and a very
compelling application in my viewpoint
and see why then we talk about this
application some object comes for this
expanding object in a large dimension
and as fast version of this object will
be very useful for us and they'll trying
to understand or after this will
eventually stumble on the definition and
that will be the way the top is going to
be structured so let's get started so
let's start off with some of the objects
which are we are Muslim very familiar
with the classical notion of expander
graphs one the whatever expand across in
formally speaking there are there these
magical graphs in which every not too
large set expands this is what an
expander graphs this and their various
ways to formalize this notion one
switched one one concrete commentary we
are formalizing this is the motion of
vertex expansion which states that any
set of vertices which is not too large
and the neighborhood of this set is
reasonably large that's vertex expansion
one could also define what square edge
expansion in which you take any set of
vertices and if you look it which is not
too large once again and if you look at
the number of edges leaving this set
compared to the number of edges that
could be leaving the set if you look at
this fraction this is a reasonable
quantity X fashion these are two
prominent or emotions of expansion then
we have a spectral notion of expansion
in which if you look at the second
eigenvalue of the normalized identity
matrix actually the maximal the second
eigenvalue and the last east eigenvalue
is the absolute value the least I can
manage and this eigenvalue is bounded
away from one this is what's called
spectral expansion of graph and equal
and definition is in terms of random
walk in which one could consider two
types of random walks on the graph one
the first random walk is you start from
a vertex and noted arbitrary uniformly
chosen brandenburg
in the grass this is just ignoring the
structure of the graph we just moved a
random vertex that's random walk one and
random walk tools you start your daily
vertex and you move to random neighbor
of this vertex specified by the ayahs of
this class this is random walking and if
you look at these and the random
coordinates notion of expander says that
if you look at these two the
corresponding transition matrices you
look at them as operators the spectral
norm of the difference between these two
operators is small is founded by some
small constants a lambda this is
equivalent to the previous notion of
spectral expansion formally what I've
written here exactly is this the J times
1 over m refers to the transition matrix
corresponding to the random walk in
which you mujra completely random vertex
a refers to the random walk in which you
move the normal in which you move your
random neighbor and what I write written
over here is you can look at the
difference of the spectral norm the
spectral norm of the difference between
these two operators at most this is
equivalent to the spectral function it's
good to keep this extra random walk it
expanded in mind because this is
something which we will come to towards
the end of the talk these these are
mirror admonitions of expanders not
necessarily equivalent but they're for
the large part they're morally
equivalent you can move from one
definition of expanded to another
definition of expanded for most
practical purposes these are not exactly
equivalent this one so and this is the
nice thing about red expanders and
graphs that is you have these zillion
different motions and they all have some
equivalent in some way they arise in
different depending on the application
they arise in different contexts but yet
there are these equal and they're
morally falutin structures that was very
rich theory behind them and of course
all of this this is what I said these
are expanders but the question is do
their existence expand this of course an
easy thing to check this all these
definitions are satisfied by the
complete complete graph is a great
expander in all in all
definitions but that's not the main
thing the key thing about expanders is
the following theorem that then exists
actually constant degree expand across
brass which are very very far from being
complete that is they have very few with
edges there number of edges only we're
in the number of witnesses
unlike the complete graph which is
quadratic and yet they have these
amazing properties of expansion this is
the most useful for a theorem that
respect expander graph that they exist
such sort of expander graphs and did not
just existing this abundantly a random
constant degree graph is an expander
graph and not just a random block you
can actually be today we all know how to
construct them explicitly super
explicitly and these fact that we know
how to do these have various
applications for us for instance these
objects where the notion of expanders
was first studied by Boston and
embarrassed by trying to understand Ural
networks and Bill's third while trying
to understand telephone networks I think
in fact the name expander graphs is due
to Finster he called it expanding graphs
in this paper so the fact that such
explicit objects exist are useful and if
you have sites basically they were
originally used it sort of construct
time-space trade-offs used as a
possibility for circuit lower bounds
they used in D randomization heavily
they use the metric embeddings and I use
them the nose proof of the PCP theorem
this gives you an alternate proof of PCP
theorem and now useful for us they have
murad applications in coding theory that
let's go into some of these applications
of coding theory so coding theory for
instance we know one it's an easy
consequence of the fact that
expanders exist actually here in this
face and one good bipartite expanders
the fact that my heart and expanders
existed immediately gives rise to
constant rate linear distance forms over
the binary alphabet this is the other
way to get this is by kind concept
improves on a large aspect and
patination
and this gives you a straightforward way
to do this then you also have the fact
that expanders exist lets you to do
distance amplification and puts it lets
you take words from a small distance
construct quotes from of large distance
lets you do this is a possible
construction of a loan group now or no
or a lot
these are combinatorial applications of
its kind of course we also have
algorithmic applications in fact we
don't know how to do these anywhere else
otherwise you know how to construct
homes which are linear time decodable
and only expander based pewds have these
properties and building on this work
these are this is the purpose if sense
people building all this work is wrong
in indict decade later showed that not
only do you have linear time you need
people records we also have been here
timelessly for different hooks and so we
have this rich theory in rapper acting
goods because of the fact that there
exists constant degree expanded words
which you can explicitly constant given
this so what's going to be question is
do these objects these expander grass
which I've had these magical properties
for us so far do they have there and do
they have analogues in higher dimensions
that's the question which this whole
program is going to study do they have
fashion where will I be in behind I am
dimensions possibly expansion in hyper
glass can we define a similar theory of
expansion and I progress and ask what is
it and because one can do this and there
are several ways to do this you could
take each of the definitions I have
mentioned or or any other definition of
expanders in the usual grass is and sort
of generalize them to the hypergraph
case and find out what consequences do
they these the generalizations have and
if we can solve as construct if these if
these generalizations of if you can
construct objects which have satisfy
that corresponding generalization and if
you can also use them for some
applications with these also because one
way of doing it other ways find out if
there is a compelling application and
figure out if they need some expanding
object or not so the both the X
directions have been so all these
directions have been sort of studied
this is still a burgeoning field we
don't really
understand what expansion is in
hypergraphs unlike the case of graphs in
which there are these different
definitions but they are all morally
will it eat service definition sorry
these multiple definitions and it's
unclear whether these are equivalent
definitions and or what
so let's actually figure out so this
talk about one or more times one of the
approaches to these extreme today
exchange the definition of expansion to
higher dimensions so one such approaches
we service extending the laplacian which
is to higher dimensions so what's the
question so I didn't mention this this
is refers to the Chivas inequality the
laplacian pumps are trying to study the
Cheetahs inequality one for any graph
the Jeep let's look at the graph G
vehicle talk the laplacian is a natural
quadratic form that is associated with
this graph which is basically this
potential function
you give me any vector X in we in n
dimension and n is the number of
vertices there's a quadratic form
associate then you can the laplacian max
this vector to a real number defined as
follows basically this it's a sum of
squares over the edges of the protein of
the difference of the magnitude of X of
the square of the difference of the
magnitude of X across the value of the
edges that's basically energy of X is
summation over the edges of x u- x me
the whole square so this is what
solution then a graph is a very useful
object while studying expansion and
rafts they have this sort of this
definition of laplacian has been
extended to hyper graphs you to works by
luis yoshida so miyashita
very recently actually just earlier this
year in which they show that for a k
uniform hyper graph now we're moving
from graphs to hyper graphs with a
number of purposes for edges possibly
more with KS are 3 or 4 or larger you
can define this motion of laplacian
edge X which is exactly as above if
someone or all the edges and you take
the difference between the largest value
you take the square of the largest x
value and the smallest x value in this
edge and take the square of this this is
our definition X naught it doesn't
doesn't come equipped with all the nice
linear algebra that in the previous
quadratic form this our natural
definition and what these works actually
shows you can talk about spectro
specification according to this you can
come up with parcel graphs which have
the same Laplace fashions and this being
fairly rich amount of work trying to
work with this sort of with this luck
rushes this is one way of trying to
extend the definition what we will do is
actually a different desk this one which
is now begun to take name on high
dimensional expand this animation
expanders and this beam comes to the
work from math in fact there were the
definitions of linear in Mechelen normal
and they have all these various
definitions of expanders or topological
expanders some homological expanders the
boundary expanders you will see some of
these really stock later tomorrow hope
you'll see in this talk and actually
late in the various talks later today a
extension of the spectral definitions
that I talked about you talk about
spectral dynamical expanders in fact you
see two definitions the link expanders
and random walk expanders these will be
true extension so two of the definitions
I gave earlier and this is what we will
try to work with once again what to so I
won't go into what these definitions I'm
going to default this definition till
the very end
so before we define it so what I won't
ask this however we define expanders one
odd thing which we wanted at least for
the graft case we wanted the complete
graph to be an excellent expander
it was the gold standard for expansion
that's how we defend whatever version of
expander we define the company's graph
was or the sort of the project ID
example for next paragraph and then
there are these faster objects which
also have this properties at which
property you
in lieu of the complete trust similarly
if you're going to be working with
either the hypergraphs what's the gold
standard the bull standard for us should
be a complete k uniform hyper graph
hyper graph which contains every
possible hyper edge of size a this
should be the gold standard it should be
the prototype whatever definition of
high dimension X function you're going
to get this should be a high dimension
and and then you're going to ask are we
would come up with some property the dis
graph satisfies and see if they're as
possible the graphs also which have
satisfied the same property this is how
we're going to come up with the
definition for HD X's then that today
we're going to ask what is the high
damage to property does the tape
complete uniform hyper graph need to
satisfy it to qualify as a HDX and once
we give this property are there even
sparser graphs that satisfy the same row
this is going to be we want to
understand this actually so we want to
understand the company so we for a large
part of the large for the initial drop
we try to understand the properties of
the complete k uniform hyper graph and
try to find out what and we look at one
particular application that should
motivate what is this expanding property
of the complete-game uniform hyper graph
that we are interested in so when
studying if I'm a that's a natural thing
to talk about is the random walk that
sort of one can associate with the
complete it's very very quiet here it's
I compass I can't feel free to stop and
ask me questions
horses as such I feel very far away what
is very very interested understand the
complete care if I'm hyper graph we want
to let us look at this on a random walk
point if you can top of what's the
random walk induced on the eight
vertices of the complete uniform this is
more or less the complete lives
under complete yeah and it's not a very
interesting object so let's look at
another random walk which is a random
walk on the edges of the complicated one
of those from one hyper edge to another
hyper edge now there are several ways to
move across this one one way in which we
could move is you move from one hyper
edge to another approach if they saw us
agree on same n vertices this is one way
you put a shingle and so these are the
sort of things which we naturally study
when you try to understand the random
walks on the complete a uniform hyper
graph and almost immediately once we
study this feeble and filter water upon
these Johnson Druce what our Johnson
ruffs Johnson graphs are these objects
in which the vertices are exactly the
hyper edges of the K uniform complete
drop that we talked about every vertex
it set up purposes are all the cases of
the universe of size N and it's edges
are exactly those pair of K sets which
have specified in specific intersection
and a priori specific intersections say
L in this case so if that was weaker any
parameter which we talked about for the
random walk this is the corresponding
Johnson drop we are interested in this
is the Johnson that we're talking about
a matter of the random walk in this
particular class so this is the graph
that naturally comes about when we try
to talk about random walks in the P a
random walk and on the edges of the K
uniform hyper graph so this is Johnson
graph this well and this is Johnson up
is a very well studied object in fact
once when you study these dance and us
to see that even though I specified it
for a particular n there's a family of
Johnson grass once you fix n NK there is
a different drums and bass for every L
depending on the intersection size
notice that actually that once you study
this graph on T right I understand the
eigen spectrum of these graph what is
that you actually have to look at all
the elves in this one they saw after you
can't look up just then you won't even
study one particular L the the other the
Johnson brows corresponding the other
and automatically pop out in fact it's
easy to see once you actually start do
the calculation is that all the junk for
a fixed N and K the other as you vary L
all of the corresponding Johnson breasts
share the same item spectrum spectrum so
in other words it's used
to actually look at these gun so all L
simultaneously know on this one and the
sort of the leaders while studying these
cyber graphs to the simply sure
viewpoint of the hyper graphs so what do
I mean by that
so let's actually so this is sort of
going to what I'm going to talk about
the simplistic view of every hyper graph
so let's actually first off the simply
should view of graphs so given any graph
given any simple graph with the set of
vertices instead of inch it's very
natural to associate a bipartite graphs
with this crafted with this particular
graph if I thought a draw is just you
have a set of vertices on one side and
the set of edges on the other side and a
vertex and edge are connected if the
work if the edge is incident on that
particular point so this is a very
natural byproduct so perverse reasons
will add yet another layer to this graph
which has just the empty set and connect
them he said to all the vertices so the
reason I'm going to be doing it as I
want
so we're going to view this three
layered graphs as the first row and
having all sets of size 0 then the next
layer and having all sets of size 1 and
the third and thirdly are having all
sets of size T which is a set of edges
so you have the empty set the vertices
and the edges and this graph is and this
sort of bound closed that is once you
have an edge you have all the lettuces
that participate in the edge and so on
so this is going to be the simplicial
viewpoint of a graph given a graph is
one who cured this fit so the graph is
going to be specified when I specify
brasses these three elements it's the
first set first layer which contains the
empty set the second layer which
contains all the opposites and the third
layer which contains all edges in the
graph of course when viewed this way the
complete graph is exactly the one in
which V is the N and E is all pairs of
this one once I do it this way it's very
clear what I should do for a pump for a
complete case what's the corresponding
simply ssin pump depletion object for
the complete uniform hyper graph we're
going to have you're going to take the
LA we were to take earlier which
corresponds to that all the case sets
that participate in the hyper graph in
the k uniform hyper graph and then down
close it you're going to construct all
layers below which is just consists of
all potential subsets of the most
ourselves so let me let's define water
simply ship complexes the simulation
complex is just a collection of subsets
of a universe of size n the fact that it
is subset closed in other words if a
subset belongs to this class and if a
subset a belongs to this class and then
there's another subset B which is a
subset of a then B should also belong to
this this is just for non closing it and
that was the reason for adding the empty
set in our one this is what a simplicial
complex is and we sort of identify the
layers each layer by it enough the size
of the set that contains it so the last
layer will refer to the actual type
edges in the hyper broth the layers
below will contain subsets of them X I
will refer for historical reasons X I
will wrestle to all sets which have I
plus 1 sizes of I plus 1 and the
dimension of the entire complex will be
the maximum I for which X is more F so
in particular for instance the complete
complete so the theta K uniform complete
hyper graph is exactly the set of
subsets the set of all subsets of size
at most K and it is the is the simply
should complex with dimension K minus 1
1 lesser and we will refer to this as
the complete complex so I will call it
the complete with the K uniform complete
hyper graph and the complete complex
will more or less the synonymous objects
to us from now onwards and just a little
note of notation before I get to what
this one so we call a simplicial complex
at sea the notice of a I have said need
not be defined only by faces of the max
dimension it could be defined by any set
of faces any circles since the sets and
then just don't close it but we will
call them to be pure if it's defined by
the faces of just the largest dimension
for this dimension and notice that once
we set the scariness of my products are
exactly pure simplicial complex these
are exactly 1 on the same object so we
know from came uniform hyper graphs to
pure simplicial complexes back and forth
just the tissue I would need one more
notation to talk about what I am going
to be doing later so we will also acute
objects we have the simplicial complex
which is this K layered object rather a
plus one layer object we're going to
equip it with one more this one we're
going to equip it with a distribution on
the last layer say let's call it the
distribution by K minus 1 this will in
turn induce a distribution on all the
layers below in a very natural way that
is you pick up the X in the top layer
according to the distribution YK minus 1
and then remove a random element and
uniformly random element from it that
gives you the distribution YK minus 2 do
move one more element you get an element
distributed according to pi K minus 3
and so on so this is when I have sort of
a joint distribution on all the layers
by this simple process say for instance
if you had worked with the complete
uniform hyper graph the natural
distribution that one would associate is
the uniform distribution on the last
layer which will in turn induce uniform
distribution on the respect to low early
layers also this need not be the case
for any other uniform hyper graph the
last even if you put the uniform
distribution on the last layer if
certain regularity conditions don't are
not satisfied the corresponding
distributions of the lower layers might
not be uniform but we'll talk we will
have these distributions in mind so once
again so this is so much for a lot of
setting up of the stage of what I mean
by uniform hyper graph we just moved
from the language's k uniform hyper
graph to simplicial complexes like you
are simply shaped complexes of time
mention k minus 1 so you will restate
our question what question was what is
this high dimension property that the
complete complex have to satisfy in
order to qualify as a HDX and then are
they sparse set versions of the complete
complex that also satisfied
Thiago property so that's going to be
the what we want to understand and the
way we do it this way motivated by an
application and I want to be different
application which is close to my area of
research my home it will something to do
with for mystically checkbooks or
somebody's now objects
very naturally arise in this context and
there we will be carrying out some sort
of past versions of expanding objects
and identities so what are publicly
check those so let's take a small
digression come talk about this objects
talk about few objects that related to
problem strictly check with proofs and
we come back to and we come back to our
question about what are the eye
dimension properties that we need of the
completeness so what does a problem
strictly check we'll close probably
should suggest an alternate
characterization of NP classical notion
of NP says that what are the languages
in NP is exactly those languages an NP
which are only time checkable but there
exists a form and time very fair such
that but every string X a there exists a
proof why's of that the way to verify
will observe the pair XY give the string
is in the language and if the string is
not in the language no matter which
string Y you provide to the verifier the
verifier is always it this is the
classical notion of NP is it exactly
those strings for which they're short
routes of membership so PCP state that
there's an alternate way in which this
rules can be rewritten so then the
classical notion of NP the proof is
checked by a deterministic verifier
which reads the entire proof its
entirety for example this could be
asserted 3sat formula and you're
checking if it's satisfiable or not the
corresponding pieces of one such
candidate which is the assignment and
the NP and verify basically has to be to
the assignment to check if it is what
PCP state is every search rules they can
be written empty such truths can be
rewritten a slightly possible longer
format which is now checkable not well
not necessarily very deterministic
verify effect when a randomized very
fair but it checks the truth very
locally in the sense that it tosses
login points
it becomes more powerful embarrassing
Norbit points but then it varies the
Lucid utmost some constant number of
locations say K over one location so
it's basically going to it's not going
to read the proof in its entirety it's
going to read the proof in very few
locations and yet
means the proof is correct for instance
more specifically if the string is in
the language and they must be one such
proof that convinces the verifier that
the string is in the language always all
the time most importantly when the
string is not in the language when X is
not in the language then no matter which
proof fight you provide to the verifier
at least two two thirds of the time even
though it looks up indeed Cape here
locations in the proof its able to
detect an inconsistency in it your
checks difference so this is what it
says that you can change every language
that is checkable in the classical
notion of empty as also this veritable
in which the verified looks at the proof
only a very very few location it only
looks at key locations this is not gonna
blend too much into these things that
but it says that every proof has this
corresponding any and any proof that is
checkable in the usual sense as this pcp
way of writing it in which you just look
at the proof and key locations and yet
are convinced with very high probability
that the proof is correct or wrong now
going to micrographs and on comments did
you plain given this so given any PCP
there is a very natural hyper graph that
you can construct or perfect it's the
what I will call the PCP hyper graph
it's this firming object the web
business of this I could rock all of the
proof locations and the hyper edges are
going to be the set of K twenties that
participate in this proof so this is
once you have given such a PCP you can
exactly so for every random point you
have a particular set of key locations
you're looking at these are going to be
the hyper edge and you can build this
hyper graph out of a PCP pieces exactly
contains the purposes are all the proof
locations and the edges hyper edges are
exactly our set of state queries in this
object and while studying this piece was
a very interesting object for us would
think the person that's trying to
construct is it is is what we like to
answer is which are these hyper graph
that supports p-series under which hyper
graphs can you actually construct PCP
switch so the natural answer is
certainly the complete complex
any hypergraphs in this one suffers
because it supports every possible equal
in what we are actually going to be
interested in are this answer - us which
also support PCP and this is what we're
trying to study it will be gonna ask are
the this fast high progress in the
reason for studying is in while studying
PCP sits happens to be an important the
number of hyper edges happens to be a
very important measure so we want to
come up with a PCP for NP in which the
number of hyper edges is as small as few
as possible and that's where we'll be
interested in this parts a notion of
hydrograph so question we've been asked
this are there what are the hydrograph
that supports TCPS for NP for say some
problem in NP say 3sat 3-coloring or
something you want to construct which
are the sort of hyper graphs which are
going to support these species and how
does one answer this question so let's
look at some of the basic building
blocks yes yeah so one of those one of
the important parameters I want to keep
this PCP this all does the nature it's
sort of related to the randomness of the
PCP I want to keep that up this will be
related to the number of hyper edges
that participate in the this graph and I
want to keep under come to the PCP which
has as few minor edges as possible
I want to make a more navigate in some
sense a people so if you look at these
two pictures at the full so there was
this length why you chose the original
MP proofs and then have a said that
there when people can be rewritten in a
slightly longer format which has this
not a much more efficient way of
checking it and how much longer will
exactly correspond to the number of
edges and this and so yeah it is true
the size of the proof seems to be the
number of services but typically when
you do these objects what you actually
care the proof when you study in
approximately the what you actually care
is not the sizes the number of the edges
that the number of randomness of the may
refer and that actually happens compared
to the number of hyper edges that the
actual quantity where is not the length
of the proofs that the number of random
points tossed by it and that happens to
be the number of hyper edges while
studying PCBs not the number of the
exponential in the number of random
points will be exactly the number of
hyper edges in the graph may be an
alternate way to say it is that if you
think of it as a CSP it will have few
constraints if you if you think of it as
a CSP it's one with the least um you
want to CSP but the task you constraints
as possible yes
this is a bit simplistic in the sense
that if it's a component in a specific
instruction then maybe at a later stage
you make every hyperedge become a proof
location actually that's what happens
for example when you do parallel
repetition and then actually having few
hyper edges does correspond to having a
short yes so in some sense means
repetition are even when you do with the
self you need to enforce this place
immediately the number of random points
the number of hyper it just becomes the
poof length rather than the actual tooth
length oh yeah so it's not the same this
is an important parameter to keep in
mind for various other reasons and while
studying pcps and so I want to construct
the hyper graphs of these kcs peace of
mind that was fitting which in which the
number of constraints is as clear as
possible it can be related way to say
what you need is saying is to make it a
label cover then the nothing now the
number of variables will be equal to the
number of constraints yes yeah
so what we want to want to see what are
these sort of hypergraph that support PC
ps4 n beep them maybe instead of doing
this we look at the existing
constructions for PC piece and see some
of the basic building blocks and see
what are the hyper graphs that naturally
arise while doing this construction so
some of the building blocks that go into
this one of them is already mentioned
early on repetition is one of the boxes
mentioned some other building blocks are
the loading test then this linearity
testing YouTube lambda we Rubenfeld the
few more others like the long-term
testing which is actually just a souped
up question of the linearity testing and
then there is also gap amplification in
fact these are the just basic 5 building
blocks almost every PCP that I know of
this one's just is just a combination of
some of these these building blocks so
the purpose of this talk I'll just focus
on more of these the low-degree test
linearity testing and see whether the
hyper graph structures that come out in
these 2001 studies these objects so
let's begin with probably the simplest
of the lot the linearity testing so here
we are given some function s function f
on on the brilliant hypercube if you're
given a brilliant function of the
hypercube and we want to check if this
function is linear or far from linear
what I mean by linear is f of X plus y
is equal to f of X plus F of Y for all
XY and long you'll be and Ruben field
suggested so following very natural test
to do it they suggested it two points x
and y AG random from the boolean
hypercube where es that the three points
corresponding to X Y X plus y and except
is this predicate is satisfied f of X
plus y is and f of X plus F of one and
they showed that if the function is in
fact linear this test will pass with
probability 1 if the function is all
firmly nailed this test will reject the
considerable problem so this test sort
of detects linearity or far from
linearity very it's very robust to how
far the function is to linearity that's
that's the completeness and soundness of
the test what what
what is the corresponding hypergraph
structure that you get from this here so
you are viewing the input as this you're
viewing the function that is a function
as a an evaluation of a bullet you're
viewing the function as you viewing the
inputs versus points and a boolean
hypercube and you're looking at various
sets of triples of points what are the
three triple appoints the triples of
points corresponding to X Y X plus y so
we are considering only these so the
hyper graph structure of this this
particular test refers to this you've
use an input space as the boolean
hypercube and you can look at these sort
of triples X Y X plus y these are the
hyper edges this value have hyper edges
of uniformity 3 and you're looking at
these hyper edges these are particular
edges that arise when you talk about
linearity dust let's keep this in mind
let's move on to the next so this is the
particular type of hyper graph structure
that comes when you when one tries one
builds PCP is using the linearity test
it's this we view the input space as 0 1
to the N and the - of the edge of hyper
edges the terrorise are naturally are
these students of points XY x + y it's
not three random points is three
correlated points x the first two being
random and third won't be the sum of the
t-test of a very similar flavor is what
square degree testing in which here
they're not no longer working with the
billionaires of it but over a large
field you are given some function which
is there and you are given the truth
table you are given the evaluation of
some function on an M dimensional space
and what you want to check this is this
function f is some finite field over get
the large finite field and what you want
to check is this no degree or is it
false and be no DB and once again ask
them to the entries there's a very
natural test for this so this is the the
picture shows us sort of this sort of
the M dimensional space in which you are
trying to check in your given the
function specifies a value for every
point on the space and what you want to
check is is this function the evaluation
of a low degree function or is it they
are far from being a low degree function
but that's not what a low degree
function is tougher
is the following very natural test is
just pick a random a fine line in the
space where he s on all the points on
the line and check if the restriction of
this function to this line is a low
degree polynomial and once as in the
linearity test what is known as if if
the function that actually no degree
then this test will pass with
probability 1 if the function is far
from no degree then in fact this test
will detect the fact that the function
is far from no degree
well it looks at the function at a very
very few of small number of locations
just looks at the function on one line
the linearity testing looked at the
function only at 3 points and yet it's
so what I want is first over here is
once again let's look at what's the
corresponding hyper graph structure that
we have with no degree testing we have
this we have you in the input space now
as an M dimensional vector space and the
hyper graph structure are corresponding
to lines in this this one you're picking
up Q so if Q is besides the field you're
looking here you are having hyper graphs
of uniform of site hyper edges of size Q
which corresponds to points on the line
you're only looking at these sort of
hyper edges in this graph hyper edges
the response each hyperedge that's
defined by this test corresponds to the
lines in this particular low degree test
and these tests both look the linearity
testing and no degree testing come very
handy in constructing PCBs in fact most
days this is not explicitly just like
the Johnson glass came what naturally
we're trying to study the complete K
uniform hyper graph whatever the
corresponding motion over here is a
grassman ravenna comes naturally with
funny ages of mobilizing the low degree
test or the linearity caste and what are
these grass dune grass the grass
boondocks are these following things
almost analogous to the Johnson rock
it's the graph whose vertices are the
set of all real original spaces in FM
and sort of want to be sloppy over here
whether it's linear spaces or affine
spaces you could work within one of the
two so on grassman usually refers to
linear spaces though in my examples
these have been our finds cases the
vertices are these
and the edges of this object are tears
of you connect to D dimensional
subspaces if their intersection is of
dimension D so this is what the grassman
gravis and the grassman rock very
naturally comes when one tries to
analyze it's not there explicitly spelt
out in the early results unloading
retesting enough but later results
actually do have the transponder appears
Benina appears explicitly in the proofs
trying to prove low-degree testing you
look at this object mostly the grassman
graph is actually in some sense a
specification of related Johnson grass
so the grassman graph of the field yes
of the parameters MVP is actually a
specification of the johnson breath with
parameters Q to the M due to the DN q to
the T does not hard to see this is this
graph is just a subclass of this
corresponding Johnson graph that gives
the size of the field and the fact since
the gospel is already a specification of
in that sense whatever what I'm trying
to say over here is the PCPs that are
constructed out of low degree tests and
linearity test the hyper edges typically
are going to correspond to like
grassland Bluffs this ones and they are
in some sense a specification of the
corresponding complete a uniform hyper
graph in this sense you can ignore that
this one so what so and just another
thing about the grassman graph just like
the complete-game uniform hyper graph at
a very natural simplicial complex
associated with it there is another
complex associated with the grassman
graph which is the subspace complex in
which just like we line
layered up the various subsets of a
particular cells here are you can layer
up various subspaces of a particular
dimension and you look at the natural
containment graphs these are the this is
what we call the subspace complex and a
grassman enough will naturally talk
about have the subspace points now what
we talked about right now is I want to
understand once again we want to
understand what are the - of structures
that Tom about while trying to study
PCBs we saw the - of the building blocks
are no degree tests and linearity
testing and they have this grassman
graph like structures those
our graphs that come about while trying
to study them seem to be fairly involved
so it will be even more simpler building
unit and try to understand what's the
underlying hyper graph that you come up
with when you're trying to study this
this is what being and then we try to
understand what's the corresponding
hyper as we talked to the flow daily
testing in arabic testing an even
simpler unit than both of them is what's
called agreement testing and this
agreement testing of actually appears in
both of them
it sort of it tries to Jen abstract out
the following feature of all the
previous two tests in this you specified
some global object s say on n points but
you not specified the global object is
not specified in one global fashion but
it's specified as an ensemble Asst local
object you specify the global object for
instance you specified it for every case
I said we're told that what the function
is are every local you you're not
specified the function globally you only
specified it mobility will specify the
function but every case is set and what
you want to ask suppose I'll give you
this specification instead of the global
specification I gave you the
specification as an ensemble of local
functions instead as a single global
function can ask do the law and some bit
of local functions can be actually suit
together to form a global function you
can they actually need patched up
together that is of course if you one
does it if they one obtains the ensemble
of local function honestly from the
global function then they can be but
there's no reason why the ensemble of
local functions are obtained so
basically for every case it there are
some local set so it's the every cases
I'm going to give a function on that
particular case it and I'm going to give
you this answer this is the way input
and curve a global function and Austin
ask do these local functions actually
arise from a single global function this
is question we've been asked this sort
of a common feature that happens in both
the linearity testing the no deviously
linear a testing every triple of points
you are given a you're given values such
that they satisfy f of X plus F of y
plus f of X plus y is zero and you ask
if they all of these going to be glued
together to get one global function in
the case of no degree test given
every line you're given a local function
and you are asked if these things can be
glued together to get a global function
and here we are asking is asking a much
more general thing asking for every case
that I am giving you the local view of
the function and I'm asking and these
local views be glued together to get a
global view let's try to make this
question a little more formal so once
again you want to ask when does the
local ensemble of functions we sued
together or group together to form a
global function the way I stated it you
need perfect if you want to get a single
global function that explains the whole
thing you need perfect local agreements
all the local you should perfectly match
with each other that is whenever to
local views are talking about the same
object they should completely match
perfectly match one way of stating this
this take any things smaller than K the
K is the size of the case that we are
looking at and and take any T of take
any subset of size T and take two
subsets s and s Prime that exchange the
steam that is TSN s Prime and if you
have the local functions completely
agree on this intersection T this work
will come perfect local agreement this
is that's what we've got perfect local
agreement you need of it if you want to
have perfect global agreement there is
if you want one single global function
that fully explains the local functions
one would need to have perfect
local event and it's this is not hard to
see at all one can easily show if you
have perfect local agreement that they I
have written it out there then one will
have perfect global agreement this is
not too hard in fact one notice that the
only thing that this proof will require
is that the Johnson grass corresponding
to j NK t is a connected graph it's not
hard to see this a few once you see that
the Johnson disconnected path you
realize that perfect local agreement
will imply perfect global average but
what about if you don't have perfect
local agreement so then we have the
approximate local agreement agreement
okay happen most of the time possibly
not all the time can we still say some
in non
function can we still say some form of
global agreement so now let's try to see
what I mean by this definition so what I
mean now is I wanna talk about
approximately Oh Kleber event what I
mean by approximately element is the
following thing so once again we are
given with the work so input the input
as I'd mentioned before is this local
ensemble of functions we have this local
ensemble of functions and we want to
check if they can be glued together to
form view together such that they arise
from a single global function you have a
local ensemble for every K set and
specify the value of the function on the
case set masking is there a global
function that explains this data and
let's look at the following sort of
local versus global remain so one way to
test whether the functions are locally
consistent with each other respect a
random P set of feisty and take two for
potential two random extensions of it
cube K sets of size two sets s and s
prime of size K and check if the
corresponding global functions FS and FS
prime agree on T on the common part they
are briefed and let's ask how frequently
does this happen suppose the surface not
perfectly all the time as before but
most of the time it happens say with
99.99% then can we say that there exists
a single global function that explains
most of the data that there exists a CAS
such that for most a sets s the
restriction of s was in fact exactly the
local functional subtle
degrees local function but say the point
998 percent probability what we want to
ask does question you ask when you ask
this just local agreement
implies global agreement since this
question sort of clear here so we have
this object we don't want to specify
this local object global object you not
specifying it in its raw format but we
are specifying it is this including in
which what we are giving is just a local
view of the function
for every case that we're just giving
the case and we want to ask if these if
you give these cases if I give you some
function like this when can I tell and
when can I guarantee that all these
local fees can be glued together to get
a single global function all I want is
some one minus epsilon and someone -
then the reason I stated as the current
results have this P flavor yep right now
I just want to say can we say something
non-trivial if I have a non trivial
local agreement can I say if I have some
if I have a modal and no clear agreement
can I say something this need not be
order epsilon it could be some other
Delta yeah and strange thing is when you
are working with the complete complex
the hassle to boost this s and this is a
non-trivial theorem which is proof a
sequence of works starting what's the
most recent of which being denote bold
path in Paris a cabinet witnessin they
no stridor they know I want and reach
myself and you all which we shall sum
for this one that is the certain setting
of parameters is not too large compared
to N and T and T is bounded both from
Aborn below then local agreement does
imply global agreement exactly the way I
stated above that you have the 1 minus
order epsilon the different setting of
parameters will change the order epsilon
to something else we do have such a
local agreement implies global agreement
and in fact not just that we can show
that the majority dependent function is
a candidate global function so you do
have and this sort of local to global
sort of phenomenon happens in all these
tests with the linearity testing no
really interesting you get to see the
global object only locally and some
local consistency is satisfied you are
able to build this global object and
you're able to show that its local
consistency satisfied then it must be
because there is a global object that
explains the data and what this these
theorems tell us the complete a uniform
hyper graph does
such a local to global agreement testing
result it is that's the statement of
these results and what we would like to
ask us are there are celebrations of the
complete complex that also satisfy this
local to global testing yeah so in your
theorem which you just laugh yeah
there's an upper bound on tea also isn't
larger piece sort of some more
information in the local agreement so
there are twenty goes all the way to K
minus one and so on you can give you cut
so we don't have the strong we don't yet
have the best form of theorems for these
so when T goes very large we do have you
won't get this one - order epsilon sort
of results and in fact you get I hope
that because if you notice the Johnson
drop the what happen happen in that
Johnson drop that Johnson graph the
movement is very little if the the
random walk because you're moving from
one case to another a set only we are
given to say minus one the diameter of
this Johnson grass is very small is very
large there so you can ensure the fact
that you you can come up to compare
examples which when T is very close to
something fundamental we do believe that
we can say strong because we have under
examples to this this the theorem asset
to state it we do believe that these
boundary these counter examples are the
worst possible examples and one would
like to do this you don't have theorems
to that extent that effect yet to be
only a good understanding when T is
bounded from K on both ends
xx is very close to K we don't yet
understand this what happens to local
versus global agreement because we have
found example to the current
theorem statements they could be other
staples we just explained that those are
the unique entre examples that happen
for example are very natural from let me
actually take this offline depending on
how much time I can give you from two
examples when T is like K minus 1 or K
minus a constant
and actually this is where you can see
that expansion happening because when T
grows very large your random walk is
kind of not expending very threats
you've uh said if T equals K you never
move you stay in place right so you
certainly don't expect this to work
and if T is K minus 1 you're moving
slowly so somehow someone can cheat you
by putting a different function in the
vicinity of the specific case set and
you won't notice it until you made
enough steps yeah so in some sense the
that you basically will be looking at
the Johnson graph G and K T and when T
is very close to K there are small sets
that do not expand and you can use those
small sets to come up with counter
examples what we would like this theorem
this should show that those are the only
compare examples to this theorem we
don't yet have such a statement but
there are counter examples because when
K T is very close to K they're asked
that the corresponding Johnson graph is
non expanding Johnson drop is a non
expanding what expanded the one step
should have second dive in it I can
value constant if you're moving slower
than you expect that to let me appear in
them
you have questions come sit outside of
audience applause continue so what I've
shown that we said so far as this
complete gay uniform hyper graph has
this very nice local to global feature
you can check that is you specify a
function only very locally is specified
by giving it on every hyper edge but yet
if some form of local consistency is
satisfied you can say that these noble
path can actually be glued together for
the most part to a single global
function now what I would like to ask
this other even structures version do
you need to actually use the complete
complex the complete uniform hyper graph
to do this our other sparser versions of
the complete complex that also have such
a local to global remainder theorem and
what was recently shown is actually yes
there are these costs there are
oscillations of the complete complex
which are far fewer edges in fact the
complete complex has n choose k then we
like n to the power k hyper edges there
are these Ramanujan complexes which are
only linear and n edges and they also
have the same property as they this
exact same theorem can be pruned by
business as a result of the new Hoffman
from a few years ago they sure but this
specific complex this there are a
different complex it's not the complete
complex it's a much much oscillation and
it also has the same local to global
feature to it and Chile but I want to
mention at this point is so in that in
some sense the Ramanujan complex here is
sort of mimicking the complete complex
for the purpose of this Agreement
testing and you like to understand in
what sense it's making what is the
property of the complete complex that
the Ramanujan complex also has that is
sufficient so moving this local to
global agreement theorem I'm going to
mention that these are not the only x
cases where we have seen such
specification
they've been a few other instances in
while studying PCPs in which we know
such specification we have an existing
test and then we sure that this even
Sparsit test that actually satisfies the
sufficient for the purpose and actually
these two classifications thumb up out
in the font
the linearity testing and low-degree
dusting so let's let me briefly mention
what are these classifications the
irradiated interesting as I mentioned is
you've given a function you are given
the a brilliant function of the bullion
hypercube then you want to check if this
linear apart from linear and will come
it doesn't add up
obtain the specification using epsilon
bias sets basically they said take the
same the LR test but then instead of
choosing the second point to be a
completely random point choose the first
point as before choose the first command
takes to be a completely random point
but the second point choose it only from
an epsilon bias set and still the whole
you can more or less show up to some
error epsilon the test will go through
except you'll get will regular the same
property so this is a much coarser
version of the behavior test the number
of hyper edges are reduced considerably
you not get to the X randomly only one
point three eight random in the next
point from a significantly smaller size
set and what think of it this and showed
us this test is enough to capture
basically done to prove the DNR in test
even such as passed hypergraph is
sufficient for the BL artist in the
context of no degree testing a similar
result was proven by Benzes on Sudan
buzzin and victors and using epsilon
biceps and subfields using Moskowitz
andross then you have the same theorem
as before remember the no degree testing
in which you pick an arbitrary line and
check the restriction of the line to
restriction of the function to the line
it's checked if it is low degree what
these works sure that how do you choose
an arbitrary line and line is not chosen
arbitrary a random line is chosen by
first choosing a random point and then a
random Direction this is how one chooses
a random line they said you can choose
the line by using much fewer bits of
randomness just choose a random point
and choose the random line not from a
random completely random direction but
only from the rap and epsilon bias said
awesome the direction is specified by
sub 3 by the entirety and they show that
even if you restrict yourself to this
class of lines which is a much much
smaller set of minds you can through the
same load elitist the no degree test has
the same feature as the what I'm trying
to say is even all of these
specification
the linearity interesting there's a
specification using epsilon biases but
the low-degree interesting this is
pacification using epsilon by assets or
subfields for agreement testing versus
pacification using the Ramanujan
complexes and what I want to understand
is in broad sense do these
specifications mimic the original object
in the first two cases it's a subset of
those conflicts in the last case it's
the complete complex there is some sense
in which you can replace for example an
agreement testing the complete complex
where this much scarcer object Ramanujan
complex and yet through the same theorem
so what is the property of the complex
that's needed in each of these things
and if you look at these closely one
naturally of the truth to go into the
proofs of all of them happens to be
there is a natural random walk
associated with all these complexes and
you want some property of this random
walk that is sort of mimicked by these
smaller specific issues so what I will
do next is actually tell you what this
random walk is there what's a random
walk and once I define the random walker
to be clear why that leads the first to
of specifications have this property so
let's go back to our motion for complex
the public is once again this layered
object and we're going to define a
random walk on a specific layer on a
slayer excite we have this complex we
have this complex
it's a K layered complex we're going to
talk about a particular random walk on
just the layer pipe so you're going to
move somewhat vertex a layer right to
another vertex in layer right you're
going to talk about two random walks one
is what I'll call the uptown random walk
and the other is going to be the down-up
random walk what's the uptown random
walk don't know what this I'll tell you
how to use for more particular vertex s
to another vertex s prime in this layer
I so natural will one way to do it is
the Uptown and I hope this you go to a
go to a set woodland are in the layer
above go to R and the layer above but
from the appropriate distribution from
the distribution Phi I plus 1
conditioned on the fact that the of the
the set above contains the smaller set
and then choose a random subset of a set
above and pick s Prime so they opt Omar
you you not step up accordingly
maintaining the distribution and moving
one step tom and that's going to be the
outbound walk that's the walk define on
the layer below the top table and the
dawn of work is a very similar walk in
which you do exactly the reverse process
that is you sort of go to given a set
yes
you pick a vertex you pick the set of
one level size load from a lower layer
from the appropriate distribution and
then pick another set that contains the
steep from the layer book in the same
way I expect so these are the two
distributions is the up long walk and
the down off walk this one so we'll have
seeded at these two walks in with very
very similar walks they look very
similar but let's actually look at it
even for the complete complex these are
actually two very different walks so if
suppose you moved from you name from a
set it suppose I was the set of vertices
say the set of cases you are yeah this
was the set of cases s was chosen for
the set of you're picking a random set
of size I might a high plus one you're
moving from a set of size I respond to
another set of I plus 1 in both walk up
down walk and the dawn of walk
notice that both these walks have a lazy
component that is there is a
considerable probability there's a
probability that will come back to the
same vertex that you started off with
that is you start with vertex s you
could come back to come back to s prime
and what does the these two walk they
make the lazy component of the optimum
walk and the dollar more a very
different even for the complete came
uniform hyper graph these are going to
be very different so the lazy component
of it just wants to share off the lazy
component these two walks happen to be
exactly the same walk for the complete
uniform - but these two walks
what I want to just says these two works
are two different walks they have
different lazy components the
probability that you come back to the
same starting point is different
in the up dog walk and the dawn of war
let's have this nature walk and let's
look at this up down up and down up walk
for the case of grass which were very
familiar you just have this regular
graph they have this three layer graph
the the first layer containing the empty
set the vertices and the edges let's try
to understand what the up long walk and
the down the walk is now required when
we talked about the graph we talked
about to talk about random walks on it
one is just choosing a random vertex a
completely random vertex notice that
this is exactly the dawn of walk because
you just work the empty set and book any
other so consider this is exactly the
down walk walk on the set of purposes
the down or open the set of vertices is
exactly choosing a random vertex in the
graph and what's the up-down walk the up
tall rock happens to be the other walk
which were associated with the set of
vertices is to choose from a vertex pick
a random neighbor and go along with a
random name with your random neighbor
this is exactly the non lazy component
of the optimum walk so if you recall our
definition of expanded was exactly this
object we said that these two walks
between the first walk which is to use a
random graphics in the second block
which is choosing a random walk on the
graph we can random neighbor these two
walks were closed in spectral no and
this will read it or in terms of these
walks is basically stating that m0 Dom -
the non lazy part of m0 up is small in
spectral mom this is exactly the usual
notion of expander graphs and whatever
it was let's just extend this definition
to the higher layer compare it to the
mouth the high dimensional competence we
serve it suppose you are given the
scalar K plus 1 layer object as call it
a lambda H DX if it has the following
property for every layer I the down the
download block - the non lazy part of
the outbound walk the spectral norm of
this difference is bounded by lot it's
not just for the zero level
that for every single level you have
this sort of thing so the subtle and
natural generalization of what we have
products expanders expanders just talked
about this random walk on the set of
vertices I am talking with a walk on a
every single level layer of the of the
simplicial complex if each of these days
I want the up the down on walk to be
close to the non lazy part of the up
down walk and if you look at this
definition it's not too hard to see that
it firstly the way we defined it it's
exactly generalizes the spectral
definition of expanders and it's not
it's very easy to see that the complete
complex and the sub this complex the
complete complex the subspace complex do
satisfy this property they always have
the property that they are bounded and
then this norm is small and you actually
go back to these objects that I had
talked about these falsifications are
countable
each of these pacification actually work
because they have the same HDX property
in them
in the truce if you want goes into the
proof each of them and looked at them
carefully the reason these pacification
work is because is because this
corresponding graph the corresponding
layer to the complex over there had this
HDX property this is the property which
I'm going to sort of please for the
purpose of this talk for a high
dimension expander that is if an epic
bit of uses from K uniform hyper graph
as the simply shut complex when I define
this notion of a block and two rocks on
each layer and sort of say the up-down
rock and the dawn of war should be sort
of similar to each other in this sense
if this is the case we will then call
the corresponding complex or lambda H DX
we will see other definitions of lambda
J's we will see you need stock yet
another definition of what it means to
be a high dimension expander and will
actually see later on that that's
equivalent to this definition and it
does this definition the surface happens
to be at the heart of the bring all the
three specifications that I've mentioned
it's because those correspond
complexes add this sort of HDX property
we were able to read prove those results
for the much scarcer versions of those
objects yeah so this is going to be
friendly words for you know what I hope
we will call as a random walk i
dimension expander the random or high
dimension expander is an object which
has the feature that the up-down walk
and the dominant whopper every layer are
close to each other if you shave off the
lazy component of the absorb all the
questions from so what we finally come
to that is yeah so for the complete
complex
I guess as small as you want in this
definition so for the complete complex
one can basically take lambda as well as
one wants because these two operators we
said are the same right yes yes for the
Subspace complex is it still the case
that the two walks are identical or you
need is it like some valium constantly
you share those the more lazy part in
both in the down upon the often walk
they become identical in the Subspace
comp I just think in the concrete
complex if you shave off the non lazy
parts they become identical we are
neglecting in this definition because
that seems to match with the graph
definition we do have then we retain the
lazy component in the down of the usual
definition even for graphs they always
have retained the this one so we're
going to retain the lazy component to
the dollop walk but we will not retain
it to the in the optimum walk we'll
shave it and the reason being and K is
not smaller than n the lazy component of
the down epoxy is very very small it's
insignificant compared to the lazy
component in October caused a
significant confident and so we shape
that also it seemed strange that you are
not sharing it wasn't more fit this is
what we were doing even for graphs we
did not shame off the lazy component of
the town of walk we always retained it
so in that sense if you want to
generalize it
you have to read in it for the dollar
weapon does retain the lazy conflict but
only for the optimum part we do know the
lazy for any other question for that
question
okay so in the sense it sort of this is
an object and you go back to these
proofs
this is an early boost amounted to this
weapon you go back to these books but
all these three Bruce Lee's this
pacification for the linearity testing
facility for the no degree testing and
the agreement testing you notice that
the reason those pools book is because
the corresponding Sparsit right I could
have some complexes have this high
dimensional property the reason they
work is because each in each of these
cases the corresponding random these
random blocks the updog random boxes the
down up random books behave very close
to each other by the way I think I
should be good to actually get an
example I want to say that the up down
walks on the dawn of rocks can actually
be behave very differently from each
other to give you examples let's try to
see this you see this do you see this
yeah yeah so let's consider the
following graph that's polite I'm going
to consider three following three
uniform hyper graph and you see what I'm
writing in which the vertex set is this
following one two three cross and the
hyper edges the hyper edges in this
graph are this filter loss
so that in all the the first components
of our investment were three distinct
things and second components sum up to
one let's look at this hyper edges and
so these are the triangles in the
particular graph so if you look at this
hyper graph X minus one as course is the
empty set X oneness zero is all the
witnesses you look at what are the edges
in this graph which is the only content
which I haven't written x2 of course is
exactly edge and x1 is set of all a X B
Y such that a not equal to B there is no
condition on Texas on the XY z-- this is
this will exactly be the edges on this
well let's look at what be up dongyeop
and the down of bacchus notice the up
down walk they look at what's they what
are they what are they triangle the
triangle star respond to it and
connecting 1 x 2 y + 3 Z a form a
triangle of X plus y plus that equals 1
this is forms a triangle in it notice
the optimum walk on the edges with only
moving from an edge to another edge in
the same triangle it will never go out
of the triangle don't walk all this is
within a triangle never can move out of
the triangle
whereas the down or block it can move
from one driving one edge to another
internet you eventually reach all the
edges that our clock is actually
connected this is connected to us on
this OD I want to claim the down of work
on edge on edges this
it's very very different from a bone
walk on the edges the Uptown walk is not
even connected whereas the down of walk
at least is connected this example of a
graph in which is a micrograph of each
solution not forget about being an eye
damage to expander it's the these two
walks are just not connected with each
other the addition here is a and I'm
doing them as elements from GF 2 okay
you have a system triangle therefore the
up don't walk would only move within the
triangle it will never leave leave the
triangle whereas the dawn of walk and
move from an H in a particular triangle
it can move it can move two edges of
other triangles also so this is an
example of the Sun actually this is not
surprising it this is an example which
comes we're studying the power of
repetition so there are cases of stuff
this is not
you see nice legs again no what do you
see this
yep
oh my doing with respect to time about
five minutes later okay we define the
solution of hydrogen expanders okay all
that's nice we seen a few saw the
difference truck ssin that came about in
ECP's which are they do satisfy this we
can ask this all given that we have this
definition can be constructed such high
dimension expander scan so we talked
about the sort of ossification of he
said we wanted we wanted a complete we
want to decay uniform hyper graph which
has this property that is in every layer
the uptown walk and the down of walk
after removing some lazy components look
similar and first the natural first
thing to do is to pick up the this graph
using pick a random
hypergraph and check if it is a high
dimension expander what can one can
notice is if if you pick a random subset
of size if you want it because came
uniform hyper graph and you wanna if you
pick a random set of hyper edges of the
number of hyper edges being n to the Q
minus one it's easy to show that this is
actually a lambda igix object and this
is it is that this proof of this
generalizes the random construction of
expanders show the random graphs is an
expander it's exactly the same goes and
previously Neff which it also shows that
this to not structured it expected of
this definition that is if you take
slightly sparse circle things like n to
the K minus one n to the K minus two or
not you can show with high probability
these are actually not HDS in fact I
don't know how to show a random object
then even exist such a high TX in this
way and the other hand we do have these
explicit constructions of some of these
HDX is due to the word ski Samuel which
name and Kaufman Oppenheim so to be
interesting to find out if there are
other constructions of such high
dimensional expanders unlike the usual
notion of expanders in drafts a random
object does not seem to satisfy this
property so till the explicit
constructions we did not even know if
such objects if they were cross pass
such objects we going to find out if
there are other random model
under which we can show such past
constructions and we don't know this
this can be good to find out other
possible and we will see this these
uptown blocks are themselves they enough
don't walk itself can be decomposed this
one up step followed by a down step and
we will see this later on actually in
the spectral thing you will actually
look it you'll break it down into K
minus T down steps and K minus T up
steps again yeah so we will do in fact
in this page the spectral treatment we
will be looking at these other animal
we'll be looking at these we're not
looking at this uptown and Donna will
just be looking at one step up and one
step down and looking at those
particular operators and looking at them
from a spectral viewpoint thanks which
will help you to answer all the
questions you asked
like okay so we can do it so okay the
point is a ribbon test is a very it's
not as a basic building block in this
sort of thing you should at the very
least have an agreement test now there
are women test the building block should
be powerful enough and further NP
computation so when you work with low
degree testing ourselves low degree
polynomials they're powerful enough to
serve us in full computations and stuff
so we don't need to know the sort of
objects you get from the Ramanujan
complexes and all have the feature to do
it if they had then you could build up
on PCP over them we don't get to know I
don't yet know if you can want to do
that that might be one in the next one
of the woods what would specify grassman
and you would like to constant degree
specification
and we expect that our example is the
matter - look I used to be certain that
you cannot specify the Johnson so you
define HDX as the spectral gap between
the down-up and non lazy up-down work at
each level to be less than at lambda but
the distribution was ultimately defined
at the level of K minus one and then
induced other on the rest of the
structure so is there a way of defining
the expansion at one level and then that
implying and expansion at all we they
are the other levels good question I
have put P but I don't I don't know yeah
I mean there should be some or some sort
of relation between this expression and
each of the different levels since
they're all derived from just one
distribution right no so here it's
defined that for each i up to k minus 1
em down - non lazy emma should be less
than lambda is it enough to define it at
the K minus ones level and then that
will force it on all the other levels
because ultimately you just have one
distribution and the downward closure of
a simplicial complex induces a
distribution on the rest
[Music]
so what's a relation between the sexes
aggression on different levels is there
a constant change like if you start at
the K - work level other difference of
lambda what happens what is the natural
implication on the other levels so first
of all you do need to like like at some
other weak assumption generally the
bound gets worse so if you have a lamb
the difference in the top level it's
supposed to get worse and the way you
know to show that still work with like a
bit indirect we need to like calculate
the constant but since today we know how
to construct these objects for a lambda
being arbitrarily small and it's okay to
just look at the definition at the top
level and then you know compensate with
a better under there - I think one is
lambda less than one over the convention
or maybe over time wiper dimension then
can more than eight hours repetitive
it's one over to keep it follow her to K
if you're changing it yeah then you can
go on without any matter to you
it is more this
okay so thank you for election thanks
for luck for the heroic